j-lo garth brooks and lady gaga are just
a few of the stars
who will help usher in the biden
administration
she has something really cool you're
going to be surprised
you're going to love it
hit the gym in miami and jetted off to
dc for tomorrow's show-stopping
performance and even though she's played
the world's biggest stage
the super bowl fiance a-rod says j-lo is
even more anxious this time around
she's most nervous about washington dc
because of the responsibility to bring
people together uh to inspire
this is not a political statement this
is a statement of unity
so this is how it's going to be all
night garth brooks will also perform in
dc
he's anxious too just uh excited nervous
all the good things you know because uh
this is history
so what's on the country superstar set
list two or three options in there
as an entertainer you always bring two
or three
you know we were lucky enough to uh we
shall be free so i don't think we'll see
that song
again here but there are plenty of songs
of love and unity that you can choose
[Music]
from
you see lady gaga will sing the national
anthem and
she's fired up black life matters
blackness matters while accepting
yolanda denise king higher ground award
from the king center
in a video message gaga gave a rousing
speech denouncing racism
i believe we have a responsibility to
unlearn to accept the honest truth about
the history of our country
we must write our wrongs without shame
and with all the attention on dc
security is a concern after the violent
riot at the capitol
more than 25 thousand national guard
troops have been deployed
president-elect biden's daughter ashley
spoke out today
are you scared for the safety of those
you love
yes i do however i also at the secret
service
are incredible he has so much protection
so we're in a new normal this year we're
having a virtual
inauguration parade everyone is
contributing from where they are
from their safe environment and i do
that through music
now i'm gonna pass the mic from my home
to yours okay i got you
dj cassidy who performed at both obama
inaugurations
and last year launched the virtual
series past mic will lead the first ever
parade across america
it'll be hosted by scandal's tv
president tony goldwyn
and will air across many tv networks do
you know who you're performing with
i will be uniting earth wind and fire
nile rogers and kathy sledge and that's
all i'm saying about it
no one's gonna know what songs how we're
doing and what we're doing in my head
well first of all you have to
be our family you have to do me our
family that has to be part of it
i'm gonna give you an incredible
response
okay dj cassidy but if you have a member
of sister sledge for the inauguration
you're doing we are family
you